well guess what Brian guess what happens
to Brian but no no I know
do you have good news and bad news but
the old eyelids oh consultation dude man
that cost Papa to grant that cost Papa
well it cost papa grand actually to have
a contest for them to look at you get
goes you have nothing in reais would fit
and that goes to your now now turns out
Papa's got to do both both lids the
Bopper I'm low as you can do one yeah I
don't know how did this work oh you were
just gonna do one I know I'm gonna do
both lids but you do the bottom part too
you see
oh yeah your other self well you got a
little saggy sack here so you got to
tighten things up on both sides that's a
nightmare now this is the guy Jason
Dimond who does the Kardashians so I
have you know hey can I have some
beautiful [ __ ] I hate to be shitty
every single Plus surgeon LA says that
no no he's on TV with it they do not
have C yeah they do testimonials for a
beautiful la great guy [ __ ] great guy
played baseball University of Rochester
all for like God do things early 6-4 6-4
handsome guy cool guy a good like a guy
who's just a cool guy la Plus surgeon
but yeah but but I mean I get why
successful is just cool you go he comes
in start stalking me you're like this
guy's [ __ ] great anyway kind of one of
us to be honest with you like you kind
of like a guy's guy you know yeah anyway
looks at me he goes like this he looks
amaizing is turn this way
turn this way he takes a stick and he
kind of like catches a little fat and he
goes very straightforward very
straightforward have you know yeah so do
you have you some way did to Kendall
Jenner I mean oh I'm sorry Kylie they
that's the greatest Kylie from you know
like it's it's the craziest a sick white
girl internat what she is now yeah you
think he's worried about your lids now
we're doing asleep dude turn it to me
I'll do the bag huh look I don't doesn't
get the nuts under his eyes done he's
from we have all that money but just
know he's like just he is like to love
handles underneath design well so and
and the other thing is O'Brien Eve
because what bride didn't realize but
you probably do because you're younger
but what Bryden realizes that all the
girls you see all the girls you see run
at walking around have had their faces
contort now I am when you say plastic
surgeon surgery to me I think a guy was
in a car accident he's got to have his
face rearranged I don't know what
plastic surgery is but plastic surgery
now the [ __ ] they do with it for
anything fillers of your eyes fillers
[ __ ] Botox lifting lifting your
[ __ ] forehead taking spots away they
can do anything to your face and so when
you see this [ __ ] you're like I start
asking the nurse and I said what what is
she was listen to me she goes area I was
saying people get this and she goes oh
oh you offshoots that College of me
she's like what I felt like I I was like
I'm not I don't want to do this I don't
know that I don't want to do this I mean
I'm already getting teased by my friends
for doing my eyes you know I can't wait
for you dud and but they can do
everything they can do a little surgical
if I got a little gobbler here they'll
do a little surgical suture pull it off
his you ask him now he said you know he
feels like pulled up a slot he's a dude
you guys are sore dies and we'll have
you back yeah yeah and I'll be back and
if you must a dick like what happens
these people is they start filled they
do the fillers they do they let be there
hey Puppet you'll be there I'm never
gonna be there guarantee you get those
like they all right I definitely like
younger I'm doing it yeah you know we
can we in fix your chicken neck and the
next you know you're getting your neck
yeah that you caring value a man your
elbows pretty wrinkly what do you say we
take a few inches off your elbow you can
do it all
why not tighten up right oh but I don't
want to be that guy cuz nice truck a
little pest to eggplants under his eyes
well why wouldn't you fix that if you
have all the money in the world you can
yeah you can you can easily easily
because it's adipose tissue I can do all
that [ __ ] you're just usin [ __ ] how
to post tissue words yours priceless
you're just tired I'm tired he said just
look less hi hon yeah I said I got the
show so I can't look you know we just
take a little easy Steve he showed me
what he's gonna do I'm like alright but
bro
obviously I'm naive obviously like the
[ __ ] they can do is nuts
like what did he give you any look there
you snitch on anybody no he's a dog he's
a professional but you can see he's got
all these people and you know I mean he
he's the doctor to all these very famous
people
but like you can do this but you can do
this if I look at you watch this if I'm
like this this is what I would do if I
were here might go you know what we're
gonna turn your nose
oh no surgery's not happening the ad
take the markers do I go how would you
do some of my dad he goes just a little
filler they can do it all the Apollo
yeah you look good maybe for a few
months and then they'll search the cave
because robbery to six months probably
goes this is strange
three to six-month concrete in our
[ __ ] eyebrows he becomes your best
friend well no no no hold on he's a bit
of a drug dealer he's different than a
drug dealer cuz you guys do your eyes
well you look great dude six months go
by and your [ __ ] eyes are hanging
down like drapes you gotta go back well
then his clientele is a lot of is young
cows oh yeah they want the facials they
don't want want all this stuff I said
Olivia so he's doing like it's just so
so mind-blowing to me it's so
mind-blowing I don't know any hit thing
about this I'm so naive to it and these
were all women in Hollywood do that he
also does facial reconstruction surgery
too though like he's he's the real deal
with that's that guy got his that guy
huh
what'd that guy get done apparently his
cheekbones is that the guy who was
married to two Spears so he said our
signature hats I was just sort of
modeling his hat yeah the man the man's
a good businessman I'll tell you that
much oh but this town vanity is the gift
that keeps on giving
vanity you're getting your brows done
what's this guy Chris Appleton hair
influence I guess the dime piece he's a
good-looking guy he is dude I might be I
want to I'm gonna take that picture and
said do you should be a doctor dr.
diamond I want to look like that guy so
for him like mandibles now you know how
they do that
hmm filler this whole line now give
you a jawline and that's filler that
right there is filler that's so [ __ ]
weird they put stuff in yeah that'll
last six months problem now you go back
in every six months when your face
starts going back to that you go back in
so they give women were shorelines well
everybody you know Bob well everybody
you know in Hollywood these actors and
actresses are doing that siller's 100%
no I was so naive I'm so naive to it I
was like Wonder Woman just for jewels no
gal gadot she's just beautiful when I've
said everyone well I don't know I don't
know personally else you guys but but
listen if you're an actress into this
town you get to a certain age you're
gonna see one of these guys and they're
about six of them and and you pay with
it and you'll pay and you'll pay what
the charger okay
yeah you'll pay what they charge or do
you got it you gotta get your fix it is
a it's the business you want to get into
if you want to make the big money let's
put it that way
well that's like the Box doctors so
that's another guy they're packed oh
yeah III about nose job from him know
you and I say I we met him but you don't
remember we're in at Sundance at chef
dance member we had a dinner yeah I was
sitting next to him at one point oh
really
yeah shorter one the guy who is married
to Jackie Maloof and he was showing me
like he's a great guy actually I really
like that Camaro his name but uh cool
dude and but he's on that show botched
yeah I remember they were gonna fix my
ears that's right oh well dude you got
to see where's that picture of I've kind
of wish I did it but no I like it
wait I gotta send you I gotta show you a
picture of what he'll do
yeah dude I mean everybody so the point
is I'm gonna be my facial from them oh
well now now hold on get happy hour
Keith give okay spritz my face well hold
hold key first bump bus take away that
she looks like Nick Nolte okay well they
kind of pulled her face out
that's what they can do now with your
face it's it's the nuttiest thing they
can make your nose longer they can do
anything I had no idea oh no no it's not
cheap they're just they're just they're
just trimming your brows up and it's 11
G's yeah yeah but that that's standard
actually that that's that can be
standard I did some shopping around
Venice two-for-one 500 bucks
yeah I'm not when it comes to my face in
my eyes I can't I can't have it by
Lena's shop around
I can't botch it shop around like a tit
but I found a Groupon yeah but there are
women walking around who are young women
who have $100,000 face mm-hmm yeah oh my
buddy's girlfriend she's 22 she's been
getting stuffed on her face and can't
tell but there's no wrinkles ever yeah I
thought that makes she's a part agent
but she's Mexican and she's been getting
it done since she was like 17 like every
few months
the theory is notice yeah a lot of laser
girls that you don't yeah you just
realize that you because the theory is
you know that wrinkles are you know
Botox you won't get ribs right you
freeze the muscles you can't move yeah
we let's do your forehead sweets but I'm
not doing it it's meats but hey man
don't say that let's see what dr.
diamond once that's my doctor now dr.
diamond hey doctor dr. D dr. D dr. D how
much for a facial now so now the facials
you can get the inste facial which is
like they use plasma your own blood they
do all kinds of [ __ ] but the Kardashian
girls that's what they do once a month
and they swear they swear by the van I
can shave 10 15 years off someone's face
each individual tooth cause between 2535
hundreds of veneers are probably the
price is part of the Instagram face
equation that's instagram face
no but that's true veneers are expensive
but yeah they pray to shave off 10 to 15
years
I mean imagine me 15 years ago I don't
think they can do it as much for guys to
girls girls a lot easier now that I know
a lot about this the middle of your face
you can give me a job like quagmire this
is completely [ __ ] me up dude what hey
hey no I don't hate and I I don't want
this happen I don't what this happen
what if they bought your eyes just you
come out this I'm not like Jeff Bezos
and ones like this but ones like a
sniper
everybody's been warning me including
our lawyer he goes careful man you do it
the wrong come out looking like a woman
it is dicey with the eyes don't don't
cut corners eyes and lips quarters on
some things but not on that doctors can
do your face
I had a friend got her lips done and I
went with her she got it done right when
she got him done the first day I'm like
damn that's correct they look super
swollen like well looks like get punched
in the lip two days go by gotten gone
yeah no they didn't last
oh that you might want on it and it
looked so painful because they take a
needle and jam it into a lip all like 30
shots what now they do it differently oh
do their yeah yeah now I have material
you get that top look hey dude
there's nothing wrong with having a full
mouth no I'm not doing any of that but
but now they say differently they have
like different materials that are softer
and all that stuff I mean it's a whole
it's a whole technology looks like you
dude I'm just telling the girl no if I
don't have lips I'm why wouldn't you do
that there's nothing worse than a girl
with no lives you have no lips you got
to do something right yeah if you have
little lips of Michael Rapaport you got
to do something yeah
and that happens yeah man see something
about it yeah that's not bad let me go
away if you ever change your mind it's
not forever yeah
girls tattoo their eyebrows tattoo their
eyeliner facial contouring is phenomenal
now speaking of facial contouring what I
realize is that every once in a while
I'll get an ear ache the top of my head
will hurt at the same time and yeah and
and one side of my throat will [ __ ]
me killing me right the tumor yeah so uh
that happens to be periodically it
happened to me like also not be like
what the [ __ ]
and then do you know what it is it's
eggplant what it's eggplant
if I eat Brazil nuts or eggplants you're
allergic to I'm [ __ ]
oh my whole I thought you would say you
know what it is well I mean ice cream
it's a brain freeze like three days
really yeah Pete my inner ear swells up
my hold on you weren't always like that
roof of my mouth you just you know oh
you know I think I was and I didn't
realize what was happening it's the
weirdest [ __ ] thing are you allergic
to you think that um I have very mild
allergies to stuff like pollen me too
and like um fur that's about it I'm
allergic to cats and grass are you grass
you grass everybody is there anybody who
can roll on grass without a shirt on
only kids can really do as you get older
you get itchy are you allergic to
anything chin just that nice and
supplement I took once member told you
have a nice and does it everybody okay
but why did you take that again nice and
that's a trigger for your brain oh like
it's a nice nice causes a flush it
builders tell you because they want that
flush what yeah it lasted for over a
month and it made you look super flabby
and fat to him I my body was just weird
nice yeah no it was it wasn't it does
something to the blood vessels
yeah so you're my huge love house for a
while and redness did not go away fur
yeah also eating a shitload of ice cream
and cake but also yeah
when you up tonight when you put nice
when you put nice on an entire apple pie
sitting and you do that constantly
yes that's gonna cause love handles good
well we should probably address the
biggest news since kovat our good friend
our brother in arms Joe Rogan Simon
Spotify yeah now we knew what's coming
hmm we know it was coming a little bird
tell us a little bit I mean Joe Rogan
but we know it's coming and then it
shocked the world when it did happen
yeah and what's fighting me is watch
people speculate how much get paid I
mean Brian know the real number yeah so
far off he's gonna be fine
they're so far off but he and I'm so
proud of him money's not an issue and we
said him I been rich for a long time but
this is different
well we price sharing this person with
me and bring them a video of my son yeah
tell them to buy a boat well pay my
household I said do so we're moon Texas
here's the proposal
you gonna buy each of us a house and we
need yachts
well [ __ ] dude I wouldn't Brian
doesn't do in the fight campaign you've
never paid to see yes 25 years I can't
get it I can't get my beak wet a little
going can't weave wet my beak who to
friends you who how many friends you
have like Brennan and Brian
[ __ ] you know what selfish [ __ ] yeah I
think it I think it's a good move for a
number of reasons I think it's not good
how YouTube has a monopoly on things and
the spriting just be monetized but they
have a monopoly on things and when a
company like that goes we don't like the
way Brian said that we're gonna do
monetize that whoa that's not what we
signed up for originally yeah we don't
like the way Brendan's talking about
kovat because maybe didn't have these
facts so we're gonna monetize that or a
shadow bandit or put it in the algorithm
so it doesn't pop up dude we just signed
up for this who's dictating well I think
what happens with anybody's dictate when
you have a lot of power like whether
it's Google whether it's Apple whether
it's YouTube you feel a responsibility
to try to make the world a better place
you just do
and again you're gonna have you're
you're gonna have your biases and so
they have these conversations in that
board but where do you stop it at that's
the big world Brian and Brennan can't
cuss anymore if they do or do monetize
it well but where
adults show yeah but you you this is
that foot then we so we can't cuss and
say sir and stuff on YouTube because
you're worried kids are gonna see it
although kids to get access to this have
to parent or the kid as they accept
accept that click on accessor right even
now there's a tool that we have to do to
say not for kids
upload again this is stuck but then
there's the shows on Hulu and Amazon it
still isn't you but it's a new play it
said no but it's relatively new in in
other words like the space is always
changing and I I just think is you get
that big and that powerful there are
these conversations you have there are a
lot of conversations you're allowed
propaganda of the the Russian hoax and
these scammers and you know and all this
political stuff which is in fact check
and well or you allow Isis videos and
isopropyl gun and stuff like that for a
while it's like we're we're you gonna
tell the line that it's and why would
you point your gun at a comedy show it's
a good question but but I would say but
in this at my point all this is well now
by Rogan jump in a Spotify and we've
been on I think we've been on Spotify
but they had video till Rowan came on
board and I think they're gonna launch
their video portion of it September I
think in September I think by then the
year they got video but by September
Brogan will be over there exclusively
but now that there's more than one
player in town now if you don't like
somewhere you can play for another team
which is our advantage I think it's best
that's the greatest thing about the
marketplace if you let people compete it
creates a very equal playing field and I
appreciate that because it's very scary
it scares me when any any time you have
five companies controlling all the
monopoly will happily that's not it but
it's like you to goes hey man Brendon
Brian when you guys joke about sucking
brian off we don't like that yeah so we
don't want on our station or our network
all right well we can go Spotify said we
can do whatever we want so when you're
over there that's cool go over there
guys alright cool man with the promise
of where you have nowhere to go and we
rely on YouTube and then they go well we
don't like the way Brian said that when
you're not gonna do [ __ ] Brian you know
I can do anything we can troll the
narrative you're not gonna do anything
so here's what else undo I'm gonna do
monetize
because I don't like what you said but
then we're gonna run our ass so we make
sure we get paid but you're not gonna
get paid yeah
even though you sure video your hard
work of seven years every week twice
that's what I'm not a week haven't
missed a single week in seven years but
listen we're gonna get the ad revenue
that's what do you monetize that's what
a monopolies are you got your goddamn
mind oh yeah your mind it's like you
it's like you said what are we supposed
to do about it
right now if there's not a player like
Spotify but that's what happens is is
another company comes in and sees that
there's a demand there's a need sees
there's a deficit sees that the
employees are not happy but you're right
I mean at this point there is there is
one player in town it's a little bit
like being a fighter for the UFC if you
don't like it you know we'll see you
over there mm-hmm
right and so I think that we are this is
a little bit of what's happened to us
inadvertently it's bound to happen well
how about our issues with Apple where we
played some video which I don't remember
some music and then okay cool you guys
use that song so now we're gonna do
where make it impossible for anybody to
find your podcast whoa dude mm-hmm
what can you give us a warning or now
let us try calling somebody and talking
about it well thank God for chin and
calling it Cass media who have contacts
the Apple and they're like it got this
and then you know then some somebody did
it and took it down yeah but what do you
mean took it down who gave you that
right dude yeah because we used a
hip-hop song and it was also fair use
cuz we're talking about it we just
played a part it was in one of it yeah
yeah well III like that but again you
can't run a business like that man we
cuz when you have creatives on your
platform one of the reasons you know I
don't have a nine-to-five because we
don't abide by the same rules as most
people we started this because you don't
want to work for somebody I don't want
to work for somebody you want to talk to
HR right here what's your problem but
Apple is like no well that's not the way
we work all right dude then Windows
somewhere else man and we there's a lot
of place to mean go well not right now
but there will be hopefully there is
yeah there is but I do think it's very
good for all of us and for everyone
included in this space and here's the
other thing what
rogon did being such a pioneer and the
godfather of podcasting at his level
it's not a Howard Stern thing where
Howard Stern got really really big and
was free for everybody and then he sold
I like how him but then he sold out
what's it serious they got paid $29.99
to listen to him from now on and there's
no video there's nothing that's the only
waking listen to Howard Stern why stop
listen I'm [ __ ] yeah I'm serious I'm
gonna pay that every month I don't have
it anymore right Spotify is free to
listen Jill Rowling it's me free is it
free yes with ads though so if you want
premium with nothing changes yeah
nothing it's free nothing changes all
you got to do is download the app and
the video I'm sure the interview has to
be great they have all this money
nothing changes but instead of the
YouTube says Spotify it's free for
everybody so you can't say he sold out
because he's not behind a paywall
now if he went over there I was like hey
it's 999 a month y'all you like dude you
chase the money you just doing that for
the money yeah no he's doing it for the
freedom I think that's a brilliant move
by Spotify such a brilliant really
their stock went up a billion dollars
after they made the roseola billion
bucks one upload a they made a lot of
money so smart and it's so smart and
they're they're gonna take over the
podcasting space because I'll tell you
when you do run in these issues with
Apple and with YouTube all due respect
but you know when when you have a couple
of people controlling that the
information highway which is a huge
problem and Spotify comes in and says go
that's very attractive that's very
attractive to it we're every creative
yeah for every creative yeah yeah man I
mean you know the thing about YouTube is
just YouTube don't have any skill
they've no deaf none of that it's based
off the creative minds on there so for
Logan Paul right okay he started doing
when he's younger it was kind of a
kiddie show he's making his video stuff
like that well Logan Paul grew up he's a
very very successful mix whatever thirty
million dollars a year he's at the top
of the charts on YouTube
well psych is a huge debt to Logan Paul
and the creative content puts out he's
getting the money from them and their
long Paul goes I wanna start podcasts
Logan Paul's look whatever 23 year old
man cuz I like porno stars I'd love to
talk to a porno star
so YouTube goes cool we're gonna do
Tai's then take you down that's not your
brand the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's the man's grown up because you
picture him over here if he decides to
do this that's his right that related to
him yep
you can't decide that's what they become
when did you two become so puritanical
with the politics the Russian the
Russian probe stuff like that via
Facebook look look how Facebook crash
like a [ __ ] when we found out
they were giving away info and allowing
this Russian propaganda to go down and
break the election do all that [ __ ] feel
like hold up how did they get all this
info the next whistle again I actually
gave them the info excuse me
the people don't trust Facebook well
that's the thing like I do think that
you have an overwhelming number of
people Trump is such a polarizing figure
just such a polarizing anybody who
stands for anything is but but but you
know with YouTube and with Google and we
know that the people running these
companies tend to lean in one direction
politically yes they just do but that's
wrestling applying they're progressive
but it's very difficult but see when you
get a lot of power it's very hard not to
mold the world in your image and how's
that work out for you though then then
well they would say great YouTube you
want to say they would say great and
dictate and be monetized yeah but their
stuff they just show you've ever had of
all time with I'm gonna go play ball
over here no no it's too late dude you
made your bet yeah well there will be a
migration if people have an option you
know but you I won't be the food these
are such powerful huge companies I don't
live it I think it's a little bit like
saying hey hurts go [ __ ] yourself
sometimes but but YouTube's gonna say
yeah yeah I mean yeah but I do think I
do think that big companies fall big
companies lose ground all the time it's
as things change as they get outdated as
their model gets outdated as they you
know there are people that's to say they
get fed up they get fed up and I don't
think I took I just can't fathom why if
you're on YouTube and mice my son has
YouTube it's with the kids account you
didn't see fine the kid Ian see me
talking [ __ ] and do our thing or and see
my stand-up or anything we've ever
didn't see that he can't he doesn't have
access to that stuff but if we're not in
the kids category
I understand for you label a kid show
yeah dude you got your P's and Q's can
be some talking about [ __ ] my mom and
stack in my aunt I can't have you do
that Brian right kids are gonna watch
now with the kids don't stack nubby we
know you don't stack my Robbie no we
know that's probably planned I apologize
for having that in the forefront of my
brain all the time I know and that's
fine but know you're going to Denver but
that's your right that's my right oh
yeah a copy works the altitude I got a
dirty looking sweet that's all yeah
don't stack my mom and my where
everybody drinks are flowing it haha
that surf and turf comes the high
altitudes you're not there then your I
can get there brother yeah but by that
time it there brother
by that time I'll get there but by that
time I'm you don't talk about [ __ ]
like that time you got some heft other
sack my aunt in my mom I know my mom is
in I know that neck shawl we have a
connection and by that family good day
you gotta have brothers and on and
cousins cousins and I'm kind of your dad
well they're bad here
well um I'm happen why don't you sit up
bad here Oh Brian's our dad let me say
and I go like this I go hey yo no I go
hey hey watch your P's and Q's I
remember that remember when I went to
Denver 10 months ago yeah I want you to
call me Dad things happen understand let
me step daddy now yeah I'm your stepdad
no your step to have you and I won't i
won't answer to Brian I love you I
called the judge maybe kids call me oh
my dad I guess my son ellipse and a fob
slappy right now no I don't want that in
my in my head cuz I'm having a good day
and it gave me Ronna about YouTube and
Apple right now and I'm also going to
pick up my s-works
levo specialized bike after this dude
it's the best bike in the world it's a
big day for me I also dropped my craft
this morning to get done as well so I
need it was you getting your list in
your old Sam you get my list oh that's
how I feel about this bike in my car so
don't put in my head stacking my mom my
aunt right now dude Wow don't do that
well why what's the matter cuz it's
stuck in your head now and you can't get
it out of your head yeah cuz I know my
mom would be down ok
well listen listen nobody's got some
hungry eyes too I'm saying I'm saying
I'm a very aged [ __ ] I'm saying we're
closer to the age
so you know hymns that up dude I owe my
lush hair to hymns if you got erectile
dysfunction God who's like I love
Brian's here well where does he get it
it's what I use I've been I've been a
proud client if you will always using it
sixty-six percent of men start to lose
their hair but a so my God we're both
over 35 your hair is going and mine's
getting for you is I I literally took a
picture on my head I had a short
correspondence via text with a doctor
mm-hmm and basically that was it and my
doctor's office or we online not an
awkward oh my god and you can do the
same thing with your dick pills one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for the bros get some hair man
no snake oil pills no gas station count
know we're talking aback by sacrifice
real sign there's real doctors real
dollar signs
it's a few quick questions doctor review
and they determine what's right for you
prescribe you medication shows up at
your door no fun damn simple doctor's
office you do it all online right now
three minutes
yes blew your brains here's my shoulders
I'd be right now you guys can get
started with your first month free go-to
for hims calm /fa TK that's for hims
calm /fa TK scripture requires an online
consultation with a physician will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate or valid only have
prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full detail
details and important safety information
remember that's for hams comm /fa TK let
me take a run at your girl hey bro hey
just you want the surf and turf
hey bro because here's the surf and
there's the turn now I've been rolling I
have a head right now yes I have
actually happen yeah yeah well Jim cuz
I'm gonna snitch because I need the
money cuz you're not paying my money I'm
gonna get one way or the other
whoa mr. John you Jeff what I have
eggplant head so I can't roll right tell
us what Jim I'm a snitch on it no oh
your eyes are crazy you have crazy eyes
I've stretched eyes yes stress I dust
eyes
what was I gonna say I wanted to talk
about one more thing in overtime about
how we're also gonna go to Spotify no
just kidding
yeah but there's a good chance lower you
say stop spreading rumors I know rumors
rumors either way the wrap this all up
we're proud of Joe Rogan I'm very proud
of Joe Rogan very proud and I just
wonder how my life for real would change
I'd travel differently as we know you
travel private yeah you gotta travel
private I can't be flying commercial I
got a money fantasize about it last
night yeah I fly private for most most
people go broke
flying private it's you don't realize
how expensive it oh yeah it's there's
that X thing with I've been on that
sweet X I've done that a few times it's
still pretty expensive pop out she
compared to regular flying and ain't you
have two million sprite pretty fun and
with your friends and we can all go to
shows together definitely I mean you
want to be in a point where you can
spend where you can afford to spend 200
grand a year on travel which is a fuss
been more than that with flying private
well I guess if you chart or a jet to
fly across country you're gonna spend
some money yeah yeah you looking at 80
grand there in back that's great from
here to Florida 80 grand you go there
and back then back so the paint that's a
lot of money a lot of me so it's in my
head are you okay I couldn't do it
that's a that's a 993 Porsche oh they
could have my key I just want you sim
first-class yeah yeah right I mean
that's crazy but you can but I'm so not
at that but yeah we're also not that
little we're so famous for their ports
that much of a swell that's a I see
people it's cool and I then the test I
[ __ ] hate TSA and all that and going
through it in parking that's a bit of a
[ __ ] at the end of the day you know
it's not a [ __ ] having an a-team or
grand in your pocket yeah yeah I just
say all that all the details our bags
and and yeah the chair check-in and you
got to be at a real even-even Toulon
mill you're not flying private papa well
you are but yeah you can spend a lot of
money you can spend a million dollars on
travel in your well but here's the thing
if you know I tried it for with the
family to Hawaii went to New York with
the fail but if you're on a tour like we
are no but if your roses are flying out
what's a mine found does you flies
private yeah
he's brilliant but he has a billion does
he have a billion dollars a billion sir
from Seinfeld
he's a billion so papa so why because he
they rented Seinfeld to Netflix for
something like six hundred million
dollars
him away David split that but he had a
billion before that he's the best car
collection in the world he does yes and
when my car gets to I'm gonna drive by
and [ __ ] on their car he has the best
car collection in the world
he's up there that's what he's up
portion thews iasts here's like the arse
he is the 918 he gets all the allocated
Porsches they're at the Malibu Canyon
the the cafe there they do the podcast
with a guy named Spike who's also in car
so they get a car and they put in a
warehouse in Santa Monica and they'll
share the car if you're a car guy we
could do this but yeah so what we do is
what they do is they look like someone
who drive for two weeks and put it back
another guy drive for two weeks but it's
their cars and then the trade did yeah
so fun Oh crow crows I'm Carla Adam Adam
Cruz old-school gearhead so if I talk
about my like current like 996 997
Porsches he's gonna think I'm talking
hieroglyphics well his math is but his
producer Matt they have a car show and
they let Matt and Adam drive a car for
you know two weeks and he should have
been a 300,000 $330,000 Aston Martin and
I was gonna take a picture of it you
didn't take a picture of it I didn't
take a picture of it I was lady she do
for me I would have now said I'm gay
it's a super Allegro new car yes yeah
yes Cheryl yep the Jerell super oh yeah
that's what he had that's a nice car eh
there's different ones here he's like
okay so yes the Fantas like I have
v12 Shara it was beautiful it was green
now he was just borrowing it
that's it that green one I think that
was it those are cool though yeah
the legend hero but Adams into old he's
an old cars he's an old just old cars
again if I talked about newer I would
like when we're at the comic store
together I had my gt2 down you look at
that thing is like yeah what is that way
what really yeah but then he knows all
about Paul Newman's like you don't
think people realize how much money on
Corolla has his car collection has to be
worked over 20 30 million dollars
yes Paul yeah I think he's has four of
the five Paul Newman cars the race cars
and drives them damn well you like but
if you type in the Paul Newman hi Jay
Leno she's got a giant head Paul Newman
watch his head a whole new Porsche price
yeah cos Jay Leno and and AM Corolla on
his show on the Jalen's garage they
drove that Paul Newman Porsche and it
wrecked they had an engine like
malfunction it [ __ ] it up and you
could tell her oh look for points so I'm
Philip paid four point four million
dollars and four but he's gotta have
some money if you can spend four point
four nine a car well that's one of like
four or five years when we'll talking
when Zonda but that you know four point
four million dollars good guys flat nose
that's crazy
that is so crazy but if you're a Paul
Newman guy and you're a 79 935 LeMans
car if you're a Paul Newman guy in your
Porsche guy that's like I don't know
what like what I don't know your wine or
whatever [ __ ] - but that's like the
Holy Grail these are like the Jordan
one-off white and red and blacks or the
it's like the Red October Yeezys like
those are not known that's it there's
only one that's it I got a text from
Julia and he goes I'm getting a Ferrari
[ __ ] you who do you think did it for you
are well you know cuz I had fries I know
for I love Ferraris and he the one he's
looking at and I have my guy grant shot
to Greg who's my car guy so I just
connected him I sent him a bunch I was
like this told me what he wants bass I
said them a few and Bronco I'm into that
Ford Bronco not for you pup now I Megan
brings I like to get it yes bring up
that Ford Bronco well yours it 2021 oh
yeah type in 2020 new Ford brother that
should I get the two-door or the I need
a truck from my you know for my judie
tzuke here my box made of stainless
hunting gear I don't know no right there
right there that's it
your Papa's getting an all-white putting
black rims on it that's a great looking
truck I'm getting that [ __ ] you Brad for
you dude yeah it is ridiculous yeah no I
wouldn't hold on
not that go back to that green one so
back to that green one it is actually
saying I can't where you saying I can't
drive be careful now
I can't drive that [ __ ] green Ford
Bronco [ __ ] are you gonna do yeah
yeah bring up the two-door that's what
I'm getting to do it you know you're
gonna do what you're gonna jump in my
backseat you know suck your thumb with
the shirt no I'm not gonna take the top
down yes I I need I need gear I need my
German Shepherds I need my guns
I need my crossbow I need a lot of my
gear they do that's so good for my
[ __ ] gear when I get oh that's that
prototype gorgeous the best what before
hit it out of the park of this their
Mustangs do two now but they hit out of
the park because they went oh you guys
are there that's so go back to other
that's from the Ford plant that's a
leaked photo of the photo that's how
it's that's the [ __ ] Bronco dude I
step forward I'm gonna get it whites
when we call juice and I'm putting them
black rims on it dude me white bronze in
LA how about that one I can have one of
these I can have that why not not for
you dude I'm young when I get my eyes
done I'm gonna look like I'm 35 all
right we get your eyes done when I get
my eyes don't go dude here eyes done you
know what what 2021 hey good news I get
bad news why bad news is you're getting
elective surgery kind of lame yeah good
news is if your eyes do get better I
might like let you in the fig boy by
club Oh does your face what's hurting
you right now I don't wanna say but be
right be so old we don't want in the
club Mike hey man I was doing Rogan and
somebody posted a terrible picture so
it's time to get those legs Liz don't I
look like this I'm doing this you see
the pictures I posted will seal
younger than me yes yeah and somebody up
there yeah somebody was me of curious
the band is back the other Brian are
back down there all those together man
uh-huh okay I don't know that guy is
that guy so old no you don't look old
there well different I look strained
they look different that was such a fun
night do you remember that night I do me
daliyah bill burr it's the best my gosh
it's the best it is it's the best we get
to be comics how funny take a break go
back you know
have a bunch I'm stuck keep posted of
you and me look at this one I laughed
sir I fell down laughing I fell down
laughing right when you saw Mina I
started laughing so [ __ ] hard look at
Tito Ortiz saying red pill I laughed so
[ __ ] hard Eddie Bravo like ah it was
so funny
whoever came out I mean I don't laugh
man that made me last so hard man oh my
god
Eddie Bravo fight companion they should
make one Brendan Schaub big boy bike
club everybody yeah that's a great meme
for all of that everything is a
loudmouth of time
show me um where do I look you're right
I thought that picture that one oh that
one with me it's a good picture tiger
was all up on you
ah he's so far it's one said your
grandfather seems nice boy and his two
dads so cute so cute
that's so cute man I was telling he's
got a great person a little Hercules
cartoon when he's a baby
yeah that's both the snakes yeah I've
actually never seen a four-year-old that
kind of like muscular development it's
crazy not to toot my own kids horn which
I'm sure every dad does who's listening
but Geoff texting last night news hey
man I would just say this he's around
kids his gyms not give us you have the
most athletic for you run I've ever seen
in my life yeah that's a fact you need
to do something with it you should
pullman track you would destroy you so
fast no he's gonna be you know who knows
swim be who knows is right buddy who
knows okay what time I have to get his
legs done it was exhausted thank you
she's been going hard in the paint he
never stops moving doesn't stop
he's so I get home it's on I so cute
today we ride our bikes in in the front
lawn just in circles for an hour
there's no he wasn't she has the
sparkling water he says he was dead
leave you here don't let anybody touch
it
don't don't let it spill what God
doesn't do
but also don't let anybody take it okay
I'm gonna go over there I'm gonna come
back I'm gonna drink some but don't let
it spill the way he was there was a
conspiratorial others and they did a
double backflip I've never seen a child
that flipped me off yep and flipped you
off yeah yeah your nose your nose is
beginning to change shape see this is
what happens when I was fighting
especially before I fought your nose I
was very different my nose is pointing
yeah
and now your nose is doing what it
happens to older me well first of all I
knows you might have the same nose and
my nose is crooked
yeah and notice the gray in my beard
yeah that's right that's what happened
to Bubba but here's what's hang on so
live you know hard like physically hard
the hardest life yeah you have yeah I
mean the amount of training and and it
just does make you that does great your
hair it's strange your body yeah yeah
look at that
look at what else was broken that one
broken that one broken that one mmm-hmm
no broken that you so much like Erin her
hand rose broke this is an older one
that one yeah damn look at that that's
you were what 20 23 24 that's 24 buddy
Wow that's [ __ ] crazy dude crazy all
righty
yeah okay well that fun going back going
through our old pictures man we have so
many yeah that's pretty great
look at that well that's under
beautifulpeople.com I doubt we're on
that bro you know might be I highly
doubt you're also in that put in put in
Bryan Callen comes up Bryan Callen hot
there you go my regular oh my god go go
back or go to the final kid post there
see them green
remember Sugar Shane Mosley yes I'm in
there and had raps on and that's how he
did the podcast yeah he did quiet with
no shirt and raps on it's very strictly
give you some good work look how
good-looking you were there I'm a cute
kid those were the days
I look like Ryan Bader five years ago
yeah Ryan better bathe in a stretch but
Wow
you look like me service you look like
his coach his wrestling coach he used to
wrestle back in the day no my neck is
thick Master Kim shirt I like those
Master Kim shirts c2 we should do
something we should do those again those
are great that that a specific one is
great with the purple that's [ __ ]
great yeah we had to a master Kim's one
again yeah I love that design I don't
know if you want to break the wood if it
ain't know what we'll do a new one love
that love that one there's hot right
there - that's I was doing that movie I
was naked yeah I hear they're starting
to go I was cute look how cute I was
back now you're cutie man cutie patootie
cutie Boop Joe has a very short torso I
can't fit now Joe goes like did you guys
I hope he didn't this joke but he's like
he goes I look like a thumb with two
thumbs one of the funniest I'm like a
thumb with two problems you just say
that on stage yeah I'm never gonna grow
tall so I'm growing east to west
he says Joe Rona's karma diet was
disappointing
well he got shred city from that that's
a plant-based news now put put Bryan
Callen young Bryan Callen dead no that's
the main picture is mad crazy yes you
are Frazier I remember this episode 2
was that one oh my god
Bryan you look so much about wait do I
do look at me there
what if that was preached hair
transplant that's crazy
okay look at be shot with this with this
with this tank okay that was on that
show us with you and rap oh well that
was now we have a couple of buttons man
buns look it Rogan right there that's a
good picture happy and there I was there
I was there I was filming that yeah you
were when was that years ago that was
sad yeah four years ago five you three
live that long ago I think so I've been
doing mayor of you once ville you a nut
dense Ville you and I have been Maddie
or juice is you and I started doing the
first fire and kid almost six years ago
Ontario had been right around then till
five or six years ago yeah that's when
you're talking about
what's next for me lids dude will last
okay I'm your thing about hair
transplant huh there's so much better
than yeah but this all becomes a
slippery slope that's a great picture of
Rogan back that was when Rogan here go
down I was boxing they sure had it
that's Rogan right there that was when
he was shredded my age and back when he
was 20
he's 29:27 yeah he was [ __ ] shredded
and fast well it's worth a lot of money
I thought he wasn't before it's fine how
your face changes all you can do is yeah
other time cuz then you know what we're
just gonna drag your dolls down like
yeah I'm gonna do a bunch of stuff oh my
god I look like Lee Harvey Oswald there
yeah that's so funny
oh my god that's hilarious
never put those together we definitely
look like him look into it that's
[ __ ] crazy we are at the guy Awards
how long ago was that dude say we looked
this up last time John 15 right yeah you
could never have a guy Awards these days
Hermit Roman was there too I miss ma
that's right
that's good people there's my old
girlfriend right there is that weird she
was gorgeous what a great girl oh you
look good dude yeah I'm like hi I look
like I look like I'm so I just look like
a scum you look like a scumbag agent
there yeah she was such a great girl
that girl the young loved her I hear so
not long now maybe more tears wasn't it
zette zette zette well it did she's had
sullivan she looks at she's an actress
we take a little Tinkerbell she was she
was an actress and outlaw a little wild
cat awesome yeah an outlaw yeah what do
you mean an outlaw don't worry about if
your buddy was over no no no no none of
that none of that she's a mother now
shut up okay she's a good person yeah
good girl smart smart no doubt very
intelligent yeah and very talented yeah
that's so cool teaches yoga now oh wow
Connecticut damn
what do you mean by outlaw though Batman
was like air outlaw I think biker gangs
I know like I like a real gypsy like a
gypsy
oh the horn like I see Mike a free
spirit a free spirit like a foot like a
forest name like willing the will
whatever you know whatever the move I
don't like the way you're talking and I
don't like your face right now god oh no
anyway you're all like no she seemed
like I don't know if no no no no no Lou
no no hey watch watch self because I'm
I'm feeling loose and I'll fight you
that I'm always down for a good fight
don't you have your leg plant [ __ ]
thing I do I might head so I have to be
a little careful yeah so here's the
thing the first thing I do I take this
thick palm it's all [ __ ] up for
mountain biking and I would slap you on
the side your head oh because I don't
know how to [ __ ] count a catch and
counter the minute I know you don't
block it yeah the minute I get I block I
I don't even know what I'm doing I go
pop I hit with the same hat fine you
always slap you you know you got
eggplant condition right bro I'm a man
your man and I stand my ground 100% I'll
tell you something now tell me what you
mean by Wildcat
this eye has been twitching for about 40
I got swishes I had some neural or
single veneers no and I don't just for
the bottom rack I'm not doing a bunch of
plastic surgery on my rat's get up my
face hey project doctor diamond back it
up he doesn't do dentistry but I'm sure
he knows somebody nobody knows the
friend I said I said I got I said I can
you give me great hair and joking around
because I know the bus my partner is the
best hair transplant guy in the business
I was like I did it with I have hair
problems I'm you're never gonna have
hair problems no I never daddy does it
you're never gonna have hair all my
daddy good you might hate my daddy we
were facetiming other day with the kit
my daddy and her facetiming and his hair
is down to here at he's 64 yeah he's
like am i I'm not coming out here - I
see tiger
I haven't seen him in since in a month
for if I'm his here's down to here now
we take the lead singer [ __ ]
journeyer yeah he looks fantastic
okay look music oh good looking guy I
told myself I'm like you like you she's
like I love he's like now I'm get sick
everything is like pawn like you do a
ponytail damn dad you should pick up the
sack she loves it she his girl mom yeah
all girls love it yeah love to have long
hair at his age and it's all silver it
looks fun the only time I had really
long hair was in college I let it grow
completely I look terrible
it didn't look that it did look good but
I had to do something with it
it's yeah I'm nice going back out
finally cuz I guy [ __ ] my hair out put
yeah I'll probably get a little
something done before we go to Houston I
can't wait for Houston Houston I'm gonna
do is to order appetizers and slap your
[ __ ] face it's just all I can think
of well you can try that's fine you can
try
I guess setup at the best steakhouse
there you're welcome oh you did because
before Papa's coming town and O'Brien
alright we're getting I'm coming like
open the whisk none around cuz they're
selling it for thank you so we're
getting some good ones we need some good
steaks it's what is the Steakhouse ask
ask your brother he wouldn't chase it up
with whiskey Pete oh we did yeah I'm
excited let's bring this up I want to
see what I'm in for
excited let's do some current events
let's do it sure is it Mastro's nah man
hold hold hold
taste of Texas hold killings stq hold up
here it is you [ __ ] steak 48 if you got
a steak and dinner at with B&B butchers
B&B butchers Houston counting up the
chicken B&B butchers yeah you have the
chicken no I want stay nope baby
butchers bride the bride down there I
won't Friday eggplant
dude what should
I think what should we do at this
because you and I are the band's back
together right like we broke we might we
might you're like jealous and San
Antonio together just as we know Santa
is my favorite place on the earth
besides LA yeah I stay at hotel Emma I
have a connection that we'll see what we
can do for you see what happen we'll see
let's see what you hear we will see
we're um alright okay now you know why
the food the people hotel Emma I love
hands down and have no investor I've no
hotel emma is the best hotel on the
planet well first a and they ask
actually the the San Antonio regulars
they don't like when I brick talk about
hotel because it's kind of their thing
yeah but you I'm you can this for season
can suck my spotted dick I write when a
hotel Emma it dude the coffee the
whiskey Bart the library the rooms what
the [ __ ] is this meats for see it [ __ ]
really keep going surgeries or some
pictures now did they send me a robe
from hotel Emma with my name on it yeah
they did what yes I'm very happy with
Hotel Emma Oh Wicky see this [ __ ]
place and then you don't need to leave
the premises because Hotel Emma's on a
campus of the three best restaurants in
San Antonio they're shopping the whiskey
bar there's well name a whiskey they
have it I said you're kidding after our
Rose had Nile birthday of a giant
library of real library with some of the
best wine in the world does that work
for you old man
[ __ ] man I'm gonna read books and drink
wine now here's the thing yeah you know
stay in the basement
oh I'm being sweet right that's what all
I asked from how beautiful - I'm telling
you've never seen thing like it's not a
chain around stains on the one I was
thinking - hell yeah bit dude this is
the number one hotel shop in the world
in San Antonio I didn't know that that
my boy which I wake a made these shoes
he operates out of there Santa in the
capital of Texas I thought it was I
should know this - because you grew up
where chin in Central Texas like Colleen
Belton you did I thought you grew up in
i know i don't know born in Korea grew
up in Texas and then Santana and
did your Texas closet is not the kappa
awesome capital that's what says oh yeah
I should have known that of course I
know what you saw Santos backup now I
knew I lost as close to San Antonio yeah
nope three hours sir I don't think so
yep make 40 minutes nope in Houston's
five hours no I'm sorry
I'm no Austin is closed hour in 18
minutes yeah to Austin that's pretty
sure we can get to Austin hearing it
Dawson that's a plane I want to though
no I don't Lee you don't understand we
don't I don't leave hotel him I stay on
campus I'm doing wine I'm in my road I
think with all alone the room service
the best but the best dude you don't be
coffee in the morning free coffee on the
house papa
look up their coffee great coffee Oh be
my mr. rose God made for the road dogs
do you guys have master to bring to the
plane no not to bring to that you guys
because you know I have some of you guys
need him no sorry yeah I can do some all
right yeah I have one a more scarf yeah
now um that's kind of exciting so close
and what are you supposed to Santa I'm
getting the day now it'll be sometime at
the end of June I think office not doing
smoke games I hope you return what I
told and I told Justin those now yeah
I'm doing Spokane with you so I know
whenever
okay well we'll find it we'll figure it
out yeah July anytime July would work
yeah hottest [ __ ] but it'll carry it
yeah you don't leave hotel Emma all
right stay in your robe your dicks out
the front yeah nice fresh coffee
yup whiskey yeah get food the service is
raising air anything better
oh and then they have the the water the
Riverwalk oh you want to walk papa
you want a bike like the river go down
the river wha yeah there's nothing now
Jays gonna take you down there and talk
your ear off because oh he did to me
Oh for two hours you walked on the river
while Jay talked my ear off really you
know the Chatty Cathy yeah he likes to
walk well what else we did you soon our
hotel yeah yeah yeah but I
well Jessie and then and then correct me
if I'm wrong San Antonio when you walk
down that River there you'll see some
people that haven't missed any meals in
a while uh you know what no you don't
they killed all the chubby people oh
yeah oh if they didn't Corona do I don't
know well that's terrible it's what I
heard okay I haven't been in a while I
hope not
yeah I don't know but it's a I saw a lot
of obesity that was there
really huh theaters on my show that's
your show but also they were they have a
Mexican place there that's open 24/7
famous Mex in place good are you gonna
[ __ ] your pants
yes it's just like your pants
go pee go for it go pee okay you stole
that chain for my boy Chris D'Elia
this is Jason Derulo run with his teeth
he made a video of himself eating corn
while it's attached to a screwdriver
there have been other videos of people
doing this in the past where there was
an asian girl who did it and she didn't
tie her hair back so her hair got caught
in it and it like ripped out of her head
oh yeah and he did a thief yes but I
also don't know if he has been years so
like maybe he does okay then it's not as
big of a deal but wow he grabbed
anything he was dating Jordin Sparks
but Papa forever mm-hmm he's bored of
[ __ ] in this one thing this is fake its
fake
yes fake don't you see a draw so it's
just fake teeth then yeah because most
celebrities have veneers right so these
veneers and then they filed them down
that's why I can't do veneers they can't
imagine them filing my teeth down mmm oh
that's the fakers villa I've ever seen
let's change the way to type so is that
guy Jason Derulo sir yes sir
that boys talented he can dance sing hmm
Goofy's talented all right
hopefully this is not how it is that
okay so over in Maryland there is a
restaurant that is opening up and
they've brought it upon themselves to
try to keep everyone as socially distant
as possible by making them wear these
like bumper tables where when two tables
touch with each other it's exactly six
feet apart so you're still socially
distancing but you can share a meal with
people that's great stupid thing I've
ever seen that's so fun stupid and
hilarious all the innovative ways okay
and in Wyoming the cases of Corona
related deaths have gone down so they're
starting to open up and the first strip
club which lies on the border of Wyoming
and Colorado is going to open up and
they're celebrating by having a masks on
clothes off a sexy strip club party okay
that looks good so you can give you
watch mask on porn no I believe that
it's pretty hot hmm have a since you're
more whiskey what oh yeah where's the
whiskey I know you're a real whiskey
lower
I love whiskey Japanese are legit
whiskey lover yeah men love it
all right I go to a strip club Texas
strip clubs I'm in a strip club in so
[ __ ] long yeah me neither
okay a couple of sad ones real quick and
I feel like you'd be awkward at a strip
club before I went when I was younger it
was fun yeah but now if now no never
I'm not gonna yeah but cheetahs in Vegas
I went there a few times you know well
younger yeah early 20s that's a good
time hey Napoleon
well I reached for this when I was
playing the video I did where they
turned it and put bad pipe music written
you guys were laughing aye aye we left
out myself laughing cuz I cuz of the
pictures because we weren't allowed to
laugh so when you're not a laugh laugh
and start laughing I was like I think I
drink some whiskey cuz you know if I'm
gonna start drinking whiskey I'm trying
not to cuz you guys yeah it's just
giggles okay like I said a couple sad
ones I remember you guys mentioning you
might know this guy you met him before
bring up yeah so ex-wwe wrestler shad I
used to see it when I first my dad
workout at Gold's all the time in Venice
he was always in there we had mutual
friends I didn't know him that well if I
know his name I found his body
yeah next to the pier his body so you
know you know what eccentric good guys
attached to the hip to his son so you
know what they told me though is uh the
lifeguards when they they want to go say
both of them and he he went no no get my
son don't about me get my son right now
and so I think he knows right path they
went right where yeah they saw him and
got his son so hopefully he knows that
sons okay they went right back together
and then he just is yeah I talked to his
best friend last night and he was crying
just a grown man crying I know I mean
I'm preparing myself but to die that way
is 39 and he was uh he's so close to his
kids I can't imagine I can't imagine
right dad
yeah great guy he was he was also in the
movie get heart if you remember when
Will Smith once get tough and is the
playground he's the guy that they fight
and gets beat up by I was also in that
movie but he I think so I could be often
there but he uh yeah it's a tragedy man
but I think a lot of people if you don't
grow up around the beach and you're in
the water those tides especially in
Venice which is where I grew up swimming
and we knew this from day one is that
the tide strong man I'll let you know
it's rip tides to it so that gets
everyone rip tides really strong but
what a lot of people that aren't
familiar the water when you get in that
Riptide your your I think your natural
kind of reactions went back into it yeah
fight the tide its ashore you know
hopefully this helped something out you
go with the tight it's gonna put you out
so I can take you to [ __ ] Japan it's
gonna spit you out and then you go
horizontal parallel and go back to the
beach but when you try and fight it I
don't know [ __ ] you Michael Phelps gonna
be a monster monster and if you're this
guy I think you was six six 260 pounds
yeah you know not not efficient swimmer
yeah the amount I mean when I went how
long were they looking for three hours
late and they didn't find him [ __ ] I
went off and he was in waist-deep water
you know that's what's really crazy
alright so I was
exactly there and I was surfing with my
buddy Kyle and I while ago the only
place we'd to it remember wouldn't you
in when black slacks about me looking
like a seal that's where we would be and
I remember saying to Kyle I got pulled
out and I went dude strong I go that
currents crazy he goes I didn't want to
say anything but it's really strong
I said well I'm not going over there but
you could because it yeah you don't
fight you go it's gonna spit you up yeah
don't fight it just go with it go with
there's an I did take there was another
gentleman I talking to Jeff about this
Suns a surfer there's another gentleman
he said there's this Mexican guy you
know Mexicans do it he's in he's had
like you burn up shirt and like [ __ ]
khakis on Dickies on and he got caught
by the the same current a couple weeks
ago and it takes him out and instead of
fighting it he knew because someone told
he's stayed afloat because yeah it's
closed on a friend float and his son
actually when he got surfboard a
longboard and brush far down one rescued
him oh wow yeah so he just let that
ripped I take him yeah he knew he's like
out it's just he's like you know a
little Mexican do bit like armadillo and
he just [ __ ] laid on his back
wet with it and then they caught up to
me you know hours later found two hours
later damn two hours two hours later he
was so he was that far out yes he well
he was packing you show can you see if
there's any youtuber ringing of people
being riding a riptide without a board I
wanted to see what it's what it's riding
without you can't but there but you know
in the more like surfers know this and
they right now all the time all the time
you can look and it shows the Riptide it
will show you right well will show you
where it's going where it ends which
starts don't watch the top one yeah let
me see this man's I just want to see
what it's holiday weekend video from a
Huntington Beach State lifeguard shows a
dramatic rescue of a frantic swimmer
caught in a rip current tonight cake how
my Orange County reporter Stacey Butler
shows us how dangerous we should see
this she was one of 500 rescues in
Huntington Beach just last week 500
weekend but I wanted to see if we can
see what do it oh there's a drone caught
I'm dramatic rescue swimmer Scott but
you can look at it right now do
if you type in graphic of Riptide in
Venice see they're moving around you
know the good thing they found his body
I have figured he'd be great white food
yeah for three because great whites are
out there nan I mean it's crazy yeah
it's just such a it's such it's so sad
yeah it's such a bummer man
happens every day it does ladies alright
what else you got yeah okay I think the
next one said to yeah it is yet another
guide I know it's um so there's
different reports about Cubs dad once
said that he was actually woken up from
his coma and he was doing okay yeah I
remember the last I heard of it yeah but
then Kobe himself said that no he's not
he's actually in critical condition and
in a coma and apparently President Putin
called beam was like whatever he's
looking out for him let us know and
apparently more than 20 people of
khabees family they're in the hospital
right now with coronavirus and then i
really yeah so this is what could be
brought that second paragraph right here
there's a lot written in the internet
about my father my father right now is
locating the hospital he's in his heart
last year and that's the thing had to do
it again and then the complications from
corona virus are making it worse i cant
about you think it could be even his
father yeah man that's just he's only
like 56 or something so they're lying
health conditions though so if you had
heart surgery you know heroic dude
here's the thing you know me and Brian
say a lot about chrome if you have an
underlying health conditions or you're
obese real problem is yeah you got a
real problem underlying health condition
get the flu get pneumonia and get any of
this stuff you have real problems man
yeah I think that's really important for
us to let people know to III nobody
Brent and I were not talking about don't
wear masks when we're what we're talking
about is that this blanket shutdown was
a problem for us and and we were talking
about government overreach and how we
weren't given a they've just arbitrarily
extending the devil it's what we were
trying to say it's a smarter way to do
things there's a targeted way to do
things without causing more damage and
that that's the debate that's the debate
with and without taking away you know
our admittin gonna hit the console all
that stuff because if it starts there
how far how how
that's reassuring government to dictate
the life you live exactly and it's
important that we say that they'd say
it's not that we were we don't want
anybody get sick and especially that how
old is narkom get off her McMahon off
his dad's dad 53 I think is 56 he's only
three years old me yeah lifelong athlete
to all 57 [ __ ] champion yeah I mean
he's it's it's a bummer alone so yeah
he's close hopefully he's all right
young man I don't know man
all right here's another update with
your tattoo artist Daniel Silva oh so it
was initially he was charged with murder
but then after the district attorney
looked at it it's he's officially
charged with murder now and then it
shows the cause here I wonder where I
highlight it I let's see here so it says
um did unlawfully and with malice
aforethought murder
oh how to have a bar so that I had to
this text so I'd look at the definition
for it please and this is from
Dictionary dot law that cause death or
great bodily harm to another person
before person commits of the crime such
mouse is required element to prove
first-degree murder and then the second
general evil and deprived state of mind
in which the purse is on concern for the
lives of others thus if a person uses a
gun to hold up a bank and innocent
bystanders killed and shootout with
police there's mouse after thought a
forethought so he's not being charged
with murder he is officially charged of
murder second degree III I think by the
time they get to it it's gonna be
manslaughter and I don't know how much
time he's gonna do yeah I don't I don't
think that that's evil has he been in
prison before I don't know type it in
has Daniel silver been I think well he
posted a picture on this crime goes this
was the the day I got a prison yeah he's
got a year in prison
mmm this isn't Italy I don't I don't see
that as malicious intent he got drunk
drove into a tree but he wasn't trying
to kill the guy so why would that be
sucky unless they get like his his task
he was like oh dude I'm gonna drive
still [ __ ] crazy up on the try and
kill ya then yes but but if you if you
if you drive drunk though you can be
charged for a murder or manslaughter
that's for sure it's probably off be
hard to find it could because of this
big news right now but I do think
something to do with maybe drugs or
something how about we go to his
Instagram there might be there right it
was honest I don't think he's on the
gram a lot these days
Oh in jail he'll be doing a lot of doing
he'll be fine in there to the other
talent i I really don't think he's do
much prison he's in jail I think right
now right yeah recovering from that
broken hip though so I know such a
talented dude but yeah I don't know okay
see what happens mm-hmm this is just a
kind of a funny one this is Virginia and
people actually did shoplifting install
having alcohol and some other stuff but
they did in like emptied out melon masks
and they got away they got away but they
caught one of them and look what their
winter melon yeah were they were driving
they were actually driving like a big
dog DNA's all over that watermelon this
Toyota Tacoma yeah
lift it up walked out that's pretty
that's pretty obvious and this is
information from LeBron James he's on a
podcast and one of his business partners
revealed that he was actually offered a
contract to go with the Dallas Cowboys
at one point he's like the biggest
Cowboys fan mm-hmm but during the NBA
lockdown so he was actually training for
a little while to possibly play football
up here and I heard from people kids you
play in high school who's the receiver
if you look up the videos insane they
said he committed the greatest like
football player of all time I'm sure a
cornerback is gonna cover him though we
be kinda like a Calvin Johnson type so
it's not but they said
there's a this isn't and this is from
the he was a I forget his name he but he
was a coach at Kansas and at the time he
was an assistant coach at North Carolina
and he went to the high school of
Michael Jordan and the football team was
running 40-yard dashes and I guess
Jordan was like all run one they this is
from that coach who is the Hall of Famer
said we clocked him at a 4 3 4 40 I
believe that and usually I always called
[ __ ] when how about the greatest
athlete of the 20th century dude he was
he was so fast Jordan when he was
younger was so fast they would call him
for traveling you ever seen him when he
was playing felt like after like history
he was so fast apparently this is that
bran was just a monster there is just a
giant like my coaching I've said this my
coach in college coach Sims raised this
a big deal whatever but hated white
people whatever all yeah that was fun
so only white guy in the room whatever
chip on his shoulder he's [ __ ] me but
anyways so his brothers Charles Woodson
that's they were stepbrothers but they
grew up together since they're like four
his brothers Charles Woodson he was you
know the greatest of all time and he was
a recruiter and he was working on our
house state and Allen Iverson was trying
to decide whether they play bass player
football and I said who's the best
recruit you've ever seen he said Allen
Iverson was a quarterback and he's the
best talent we as far as on their on
their paper on paper like capabilities
potential said Allen Iverson was the
best football player he's ever seen on
camera I heard that when the guy was
talking about Michael Vick he goes
Michael Vick's the best quarterback well
Allen Iverson's the best quarterback to
come at it man yes and I went I don't
know yeah they might you watch to be
like oh he's filthy filthy yeah did I
have video on oh yeah you need to find
the high school video these kids just
didn't have a chance not a chance just
crazy speed just too small for this this
Sims who's been on the football circuit
forever you know he played at Bowling
Green played a little bit in the NFL
he's like the best player I've ever seen
allen iverson hands down God have any
pro college high school kid but just too
small I guess for the NFL at the time
yeah but you know if you if you had the
the Mayfield's and the drew breezes and
the you know Russell Wilson he probably
got very very thick
remember iris um 165 pounds you know
that's and I'm and I promise you that
Russell Wilson if you look at his legs
I promise gotta be 210 to finish thick
like I told those guys are always so
much bigger than you think
like look at Sanchez Sanchez is [ __ ]
you know these pro it a prototypical
quarterback yeah marks Russell Wilson's
small for quarterbacks just drew you
look at drew drew brees three bases
small 200 pounds so still yeah yeah
six feet offense line averages offense
line height 65 you know tackles 65 it's
nuts yeah throw between those two
pillars they got Baker Mayfield who's
maybe six foot you know crazy to was not
huge the Alabama quarterback you know
he's not giant I think he's pretty how
biggest or he's gonna be six to two or
from Alabama I think he's it got that
Samoan thickness though oh he's not that
good
he looks skinny but I promise you he's a
lot heavier six feet
yeah but he's Samoan so he said like
you're looking a guy like that and you
be like what do you weigh about 205 and
he's like 270 like they're so thick 217
yeah six-foot-two you know he's not big
yeah that was the knock on him that was
a knock if there is a knock
he's only six foot you know 215 pounds
most healthy guy in the dress who was it
who played for Miami kiya the
quarterback kaya was a brad Kyle Noke I
know that he was University of Miami
quarterback phenomenal player a quarter
muna Phil no did he go to the NFL is
what I want to know because I noticed I
know his father
oh I don't say phenomenal quarterback no
he was great in Miami right he was not
great at Miami oh they they still eat
[ __ ] he was alright he go to the enemy I
know he's a
mix kid likes kids it's fathers Canyon
you don't say phenomenal we all be
careful were phenomenal careful with
that he was in the top 50 quarterbacks
in that year college to you
really if he if you got a university you
went to university Miami quarterbacks he
probably the quarterback there yeah
118 did they not if what pictures they
have there's these kya K a why a ke why
didn't L be uh they're iconic i-64 you
see Miami yeah now is he is he from
playing he was dropping his dad he was
drafted in six rounds you got to be
careful with me I'm careful right above
that all right now Detroit Lions 14 3 on
16 he's played for five different NFL
team ok series Terran I've been doing do
me wrong he's in the NFL and he's
playing yeah yeah what the bangles right
now at them and 2019 it looks like he's
like a third string guy unrestricted
free agent start of a new league year in
March I don't know how it works yeah I
know phenomenal mmm yeah back up guy
back up BC but then that's for this
being Freddie she's not even back yet
so he's like when you bounce around
Easter Show you're kind of creation that
they use they they recruit you as an
athlete well no the roster at
quarterback and they brought him in see
what he can do you know yeah he's from
LA he's a stud yeah but he's not sorry
so I knew his dad really well as to have
was right around MADtv and I knew his
mother didn't move to his mother
so so and I remember I remember the kid
when he was 10 thrown football with him
he's a stud named out yeah I'm just
saying phenomenal is not hard to find
him yeah and the in the NFL or in
college yeah I think he's a freshman he
was getting he was all ACC but he was at
you know which is insane right
it looks like Donna fell he's trying to
find his way
yeah she's not either practice squad guy
what does that mean you're on the team
really you're on the 53-man roster
really but they like they finally hold
to me it's not man miners no you're
you're a professional football player
but you're on the practice squad so you
make maybe fifty seventy-five thousand
dollars Wow you're hustling dude
wow you're hustling like anything else
there's no when you're a quarterback
it's like tough to break you in the
quarterback tough to break in ha Tebow
the tough star in the world it's the
toughest job no and professor sports
being a NFL court is starting there's
this pop good Oh Brad great guy the Sun
goes close [ __ ] to Miami so must be a
[ __ ] stunt yes yes yeah what else you
got
alright so remember how we're looking
forever for that big buff girl that's
chin so a guy named Mark Cuban mark mark
urban message mark same being the
Democratic represents not out of order
firm for 1020 I like that choice lock
burden Biden economic stud you know like
now did now during the lockdown
did he call on a restaurant this players
out to get shut down and snitch done he
did I don't like that yeah I wonder if
there's more to that story though
there's not because so far I liked him
he's been inviting yeah yeah that's some
work done yeah yeah your lives done yeah
doesn't has he right let me see what's
going on he's a powerful dude I saw him
in uh in a hotel what it was we're going
for a Showtime yeah he's an interesting
character did a great job with the
Dallas Mavericks yeah great job smart
guy seems cool seems like a personable
guy he seems like one of us I don't I
don't know his politics I don't want to
jump on the bandwagon yet the practical
yeah I think my paw
this is practical yeah choppers on them
no stream by the way so that girl this
we vote for another celebrity though for
this yeah but a guy who's done it in the
economic space more than once right
see it's very very very successful tech
very successful as a sports owner that's
attractive to me
notice how to manage knows how to
motivate employees that's that's he's
got some good ideas thoughtful so when
you're successful in two arenas I'm a
fan does he look a little like ray Longo
or is it just me a little bit little bit
little bit Snyder back off spot-on
that's spot-on
okay here's the girl I don't know if you
want a billionaire as a as a president
though um it's a weird thing dynamic
equity Trump is yeah you know I don't
mind it yeah sir Natalia now that's a
Russian gal I don't honestly I don't
know if it's a girl to be honest asking
guns dude I think this is one of those
cases like that I was pretty though
right for yes pretty and full of deca
yes and could have been we may be
dealing with a gender-fluid situation
that's our thinking hey man oh dear you
like just twenty two in my phone if
that's a that's a person I'm I'm gonna
go ahead and tell you that man a woman
that's 100 peso a big woman you don't do
you the man I do I think it used to be a
man I don't know I think that I don't
know I need more info to see this
there's there's there's no question in
my mind you can tell by the ass looks
like real long and not about this now
the lips are natural so this is good I
try to play the videos but for some
reason I think the videos don't doesn't
show her she always sounds like a cover
of it well there you go yeah Brian
mother's ass those quads are bodacious
yeah I would have to say that that's
offense that's that was
other girls like that out there though
I'm just looking at the structure of the
face but don't you think there's also
kind of like the Iranian health thing
I'm saying no realistic yes some stuff
going on here no that's real
oh yeah natural beef well that's that I
believe was probably a fella at one
point and has now got one there you
might go that far oh the one in this one
that one in the one next to her that
kind of helps Bryant's got into my head
to come to my head I'm gonna go ahead
and say all right I know I'm just let's
say hypothetical world yeah we do a show
in Russia yeah and I'm gonna get done
with the show and she's gonna be laying
in here for now I know dude hypothetical
we're just talking
the Italian she goes I would love to
hang out after this yeah let's just talk
we're gonna talk it seemed you know you
know it's it's that time like you kissed
that type I get all nervous and I say
huh
what do you want to talk about and she
was working out your what you liked
working out right yeah I like big
athletic guys I mean okay I'm confused
yeah and then I say and then next thing
I look over me like this oh that's
that's what stars up what happens
sometimes
yeah that's that's gonna be an issue oh
go to her 14 years old that that's a
woman dude that is a woman on a lot of
Russian supplement I'm not I'm not I
don't believe that that's her face on I
think that's a Photoshop face what yeah
I do
Jim do you think very well be a boy I
think a lot of this stuff is fakes like
I don't know it could be a boy who
wanted to be a girl at two it could be
that but I mean sometimes she looks
bigger in some pictures that's out of
control yes she's so just out of control
so jus yeah it's definitely Bluff but
that's like Sarah that looks more
realistic right does it
those are 22 inch arms I mean least a
little bit nah you know what she's in a
tanning bed up there or down out tan
about the green tan on it I pride jump
it well what you're I'm full of vodka
wow you're because you're a
little--you're
around the waist and the hip ratio in
the ass and the legs and look legs yeah
and so will your what you're looking at
is there any way you could take 3 inches
off the on though it means a man yeah
she's a bigger girl than you are and
well yeah now I don't think it's a man I
think it's a girl who took a lot of
Russian supplements yeah well I think I
think you guys a man you're in that's
that's way too much that's so well done
that's way too my house yes I've never
seen too much for you yeah that's simply
too much alright and also used to be
this something's going on there then a
happen there's some gluts papa
I'm not bad at it surprisingly yeah what
the real big shoulders and she's getting
a huge sneaky-sneak you would sneak off
so you'd be like I do yeah that's a
really interesting of Ruben that's a
group that's that is a group of us
children or they are its Asura it's it's
a it's a satanic circle of you know do
they drink blood prop is definitely a
lot of blood drinking and circus going
and a lot of her flowers are so big yeah
there's a lot of perversion those quads
are so big I think that's her man I
don't but I landed plane so she's into
that God look at her [ __ ] quads there
dude I know they were taking yeah it's
it's a bike it's out control we're yet
on this cat I too much well if you want
to have no idea I honestly have no idea
you know it looks like a lot of work a
lot of dedication
it looks like should you win like the
mr. Olympia I'm sorry I think she has
something on her profile that says IFBB
Pro so she you're close
well yeah and even I'm rural deadlift
been fresh arm lift record holder and
the women's division so you're not off
the toe
whose net SOVA I'm a Amazon uh yeah yeah
she's very popular - is she well you
know half a million followers yeah
god she's juicy those quads be tough I
don't know do I feel like she'd be a
good time for a bright bright just
opposed oh no okay whoa this is cool
as usual Elizabeth really looks amazing
for age such a time for any age actually
right so this is yeah so this is her 21
years ago in this dress and she posted a
picture recently with the same dress
look at her she's amazing her legs
I know shiny she's a freak I'm the only
the only person better-looking than she
is in the family is her son agreed I
mean there's a picture of Vera Wang that
she posted in a sports bra at 70 and she
looks phenomenal pure wine
yeah Vera Wang really no clone yeah this
is her a 70 hmm come on
Wow that's better Wang 70 there mm-hmm
Asians man Asians pretty impressive -
gonna lay off for a huh her face doesn't
age a date well until you get yeah of
course and personal yeah you know time
[Music]
timeless it awaits for no one
your barber you can age gracefully you
can embrace it or you can live get some
filler gets your lids done you can come
to Houston see Brennan and I in person
all sold out when he had more take 28 29
30
they are they are expanding capacity
from what I understand some tickets will
be coming yeah I'm not in Washington DC
the 1890 first I have to call Jenny
she'll take that off I'm and spoke in
June
25th through 27th that Saturday the 27th
we're doing our inaugural thick boy bike
ride you can email sick boy ride at
gmail.com to sign up for location all
the other info you need we have over a
hundred riders already which is insane
on how long I fit on the trail but we'll
figure it out spoke in and that's that
the trail will be the Beacon Hill our
first thick boy get-together is June
27th but I'll be doing comedy that
Thursday the 25th Friday 26 and then
Saturday the 27th get your tix now
spoken comedy club briancon well be with
me are you going together then Salt Lake
City is July 16th through the 18th at
wiseguys Bryan Callen will also be there
with me yep and then we'll have more
dates coming up for you guys but after
that Tampa is nine eighteen through nine
19 Austin nine twenty four through nine
twenty six get your tickets tik calm for
anything thick boy murtra lady goes
thick boy calm get you some thick-ass
merch for your thick ass self yeah that
it be that's it brother I'm antsy on the
trails kids this the found kid we're out
ladies and gentlemen the cats rapt
champion himself little brows
I'm right in his feet like Brennan is
right in the bite I was just trying to
be nice I was just minding my business
but you're gonna make me wanna fight I
am not lying to them no battle and I'm
gonna win
if prison is busy with Tiger the number
sick Brian on them wait hey if you talk
[ __ ] I'm gonna need a back brace be in
first place go the last place do with
the guest of the year that's a rat race
shut up [ __ ] I wouldn't get it there's
a strap things I am thinking that does
yuppies always effortless until we see
him with the ring away while he is
fasting yeah bring this car go fast
that's a lot of cash they said Brian
sweet what this tardiness turn on the
smoke [ __ ] with this card again I'm just
kidding Brian man we think you're really
funny I bet Chris is about to call you
and show you a lot of money you've been
trying to Sunday man so long that you
should call him Sonny yeah they want the
belt they gonna have to come and take it
from me
I've been up late working like I'm Jimmy
Fallon y'all been coming up short like
you're Bryan Callen
laughing laughing laughing then I hit
them with the right don't mess with the
kid unless you boys know how to fight I
[Music]
just thinking in this thing and they
thought I was trippin like Austin you're
different I'm awfully different apart
from the fact that the parts of envenom
since I was a kid in a bingo and they
know I really don't stuff a lot wrote
that last one in is chick-fil-a parking
lot all of my haters they piped on bar
Cola I run this [ __ ] man I go to Tony
Stark a lot
I can't believe that he's did this when
I'm in the booth I'm a chemist hackathon
where the man never your PIN engine I'm
independent and you're in the printers
and Brennan is looking like Drake just
got to cover a muscle and fitness
I do not know where my pin is I think it
caught fire and burn like the British
promise I'm on them turn their heads and
look again Brian's probably trying to
read an excerpt from a book again out
loud guy ain't cause like all you have
to do is look within I hate the beating
cook again they typical like to poop in
Brian Kyle's been around the world Saudi
Arabia to Lebanon Greece Pakistan the
beekeeper of out of Romania shortage of
ribs so they hate on you they let them
know not to play with your thumbs as
soon as you catch a minute hold you're
gonna turn it into WrestleMania
up late working like I'm Jimmy Fallon
y'all been coming up short like you're
Bryan Callen
laughing laughing laughing then I hit
them with the right don't mess with the
kid unless you boys know how to fight
fighter and the kid everything
[Music]